can you give advice to young people
in high school and college
maybe they're interested in economics
maybe they have other career ideas what
advice would you give them about a
career they can have that they could be
proud of or a life they can be proud of
mainly in a career i say don't do an
economics degree
okay i say
there's a there's a little book
on
comics econ comics taking the con out of
economics
um so they should start with that
and then say screw it to an economics
degree yeah because what you learn is an
obsolete technology learning economics
at a university is like learning it's
all make astronomy
okay earth centric equilibrium
um
you know epi cycles being added to make
your models fit the data it's not that
economics is not a discipline worth
deeply studying it's that the university
education around that is so bad it's bad
yeah so i'd say learn system dynamics
do a course in system dynamics which you
can apply in any field
and then apply what you learn out of
system dynamics to the issues of
economics if that's what interests you
so get a sort of base engineering
education a base engineering education
that is far better than doing an
economics degree in terms of life
i know my life is pretty chaotic in many
many ways my friends friends and family
will tell me that every opportunity uh
but the thing is i once had this i'll
tell you an example of a really funny
incident that occurred to me because i
let the student revolt at sydney
university as i mentioned i was 20 years
old
and then in my thinking about 28 or so i
went to a restaurant one night and i
found a bunch of guys all guys
who'd done accounting at the university
but also been part of the student revolt
so they hadn't seen me for about a
decade and they said to what have been
doing steve and i talked about what i'd
done so i've been a school teacher for a
while i then worked in overseas aid
i was doing computer programming at the
time and i've forgotten what else i was
doing at that point so i explained it to
all of them and they were at a buck's
night one of them having a wedding you
know coming up the next week and uh one
of them said i wish i'd done that
and there was silence around the table
that was obviously silent agreement and
i looked at them and said hang on guys
look at the downside of my life you know
like like i've you've all you're getting
married i don't have a girlfriend right
now um
you've all got secure jobs i'm
unemployed okay i've done it you own a
house i haven't got a car you know look
at the downside of my life and the bloke
was the kingpin of that group a very
innovative bunch of guys in the student
revolt so you said steve
we would still
all rather have done what you have done
and they did accounting because it was
safe
they always got a job they were bored
shitless
did you have a sense that
the chaos you're always
jumping into
was dangerous or was it just the poor
pull of it that i simply couldn't not do
it yeah it was part of me that i
couldn't swallow this economic stuff
once i was exposed to why it was so
wrong then i was on a on a crusade to
make it right
and that's been part of my nature all
through my life i don't know why
so it wasn't that i made a choice to do
it is that i couldn't be true to myself
without doing it and i find a lot of
people get caught in alive where they're
doing it because it works for some
financial or other reason but they're
not being true to themselves and as as
messy as my life as much [ __ ] i've got
myself caught up in and there's a lot of
that in my personal and financial life
right now which is a pain in the ass
i would rather have had that nature than
not
you